Kuwait has just rolled out
a virtual news anchor her name is
artificial intelligence equate news what
kind of news do you prefer let's hear
your opinions
very nice looking blonde woman very
pretty but not too pretty so you're
still you're still hearing the news from
her fed hot is an old Kuwaiti name it
refers to Silver and I think the reason
they named for that is because we
imagine robots to be metallic kind of
like you know on The Jetsons or
something like that she is not though
she looks like a person if you just
watched her read the news you would
think this is a real person and so a lot
of people especially conservatives are
going to hear this story they're going
to see this story and they're going to
say oh I will I'll never watch that I'm
not going to get my news from a robot
you're not going to trick me you will
you will get your news from a robot at
some point